oder war es eher als übels gelder - der
beste ort um neue blockbuster mit allen
sinnen in ihrem gesamten detailreichtum
zu erleben der geruch von frischem
popcorn oder nachos die typischen roten
sessel und vor allem eine riesenleinwand
mit exzellenten bild und ton wenn da
nicht die nervigen anderen gäste werden
aufstehen mit einem film an den
wichtigsten stellen das handy auch
voller bildschirmhelligkeit rausholen
oder die ganze zeit mit dem sitz nach
banken wie schön wäre es wenn man sich
damit nicht rumschlagen musste wie schön
wäre es wenn man nur mit den eigenen
freunden im kino saal sitzen würde wie
schön wäre es ein eigenes kino zu haben
viel spaß mit ich habe in 24 stunden
mein eigenes kino eröffnet natürlich
will ich das ganze aber nicht irgendwie
machen wir brauchen richtige ausstatten
wir brauchen richtige kinosessel wir
brauchen eine richtige popcorn maschine
unterbrochen wichtige bienen da freue
ich mich auf die suche nach einem
verleih gemacht der all das hat und da
rufen jetzt als aller erstes mal an und
fragen ob die zeit haben das für uns
hierhin zu bringen und mit uns ein
echtes kino aufzumachen ich rufe an weil
ich mich für ihn dessen popcornmaschine
und nacho wärmer interessiere ich danke
herr let's go wir brauchen aber noch ein
ort wo das ganze machen können wir haben
ein großes studio und dass wir komplett
leeren können und hieraus entsteht ein
echtes kino merkt euch schon mal wie es
hier aussieht dahin zwei stunden werdet
ihr das hier nicht mehr wiedererkennt
oh mein gott herzlich willkommen in
meiner eigenen persönlichen kino
leinwand steht jetzt fehlt der beamer
und die gesamte andere aus stadt und
bevor wir hier irgendwas rein stellen
können muss dieser ganze scheiß erstmal
raus deswegen fange an das komplette
studio mehr zu holen
[Musik]
der verleih von den roten sesseln der
popcornmaschine und der nation maschinen
ist da und wir fangen jetzt an den
kompletten raum mit diesen typischen
roten kinosessel zu füllen
[Musik]
es ist vollbracht nach zwei stunden
aufbauen sachen schleppen und noch mal
schnell in die metro fahren und alles
holen was wir bis dato noch nicht hatten
sind wir fertig und können euch das
ergebnis zeigen bevor die ganzen gäste
jetzt kommen warum ich eine schürze an
haber ist eine gute frage ich musste
irgendwie so wirken als würde ich
arbeiten und das war das einzige was wir
passend hatten willkommen in unserem
kino
[Musik]
im roten sesseln und guten snacks gibt
es aber genau eine sache die kino noch
ganz besonders ausmachen gutes bild und
guter ton deswegen bin ich überhaupt das
extreme dieses video mit ihren vier
kabinen die studie mit bis zu 300 zoll
vier kabel ist dieser beamer der
perfekte begleiter um in unserem kino
setup echtes kinogefühl aufkommen zu
lassen wie man es super klein handlich
und ziemlich schick dabei sieht nicht
nur gut aus sondern ist auch super
einfach zu nutzen den beamer
einsatzbereit zu machen dauert nicht
länger als sechs sekunden dank auto
trapezkorrektur und autofokus das ist
wirklich super easy anstecken anmachen
let's go dank zwei 1200 lumen ist der
beamer auch bei tageslicht zu gebrauchen
und dann 2500 stunden lebenszeit der
lampe für lange zeit eure entertainment
perfekten kino sound liefern die intern
verbrauchten harman kardon box was mich
aber glaube ich am meisten beeindruckt
hat ist dass der beamer so gut mit
android funktioniert also man macht
ihnen an man muss nichts extra anstecken
man hat alle apps die man wirklich
braucht und es funktioniert super
flüssig also das betriebssystem der
prozessor sind so gut dass man den super
gut benutzen kann ohne extra sachen
ansteckend zu müssen in wien ps 5 oder
ein apple tv und er funktioniert einfach
so genauso haben wir den im kinocenter
benutzt aber dank des gaming modus
konnten wir in den tagen danach auf dem
riesen mario kart metal mit allen jungs
hier im beruf anstalten was eine menge
spaß gemacht hat deswegen einen riesen
dank an extrem vielen dank dass die mich
um dieses gesamte projekt er
unterstützen check den link in der video
beschreibung konnten die rechtsextremen
zu unserer linken seht ihr 24 sitzplätze
in echten roten kinosessel sowie der
rechten seite ein absolut traumhaftes
bild aus dem extreme 4k projektor
inklusive harman kardon sound der uns
gleich feinst unterhalten wird und dann
das absolute highlight kommt einmal
extra stand mit popcorn maschine
nachschub an einem kühlschrank voll mit
getränken sind im endeffekt jetzt echt
ziemlich nah an im normalen echten kino
dran und ich bin absolut haben die leute
gleich hier zu begrüßen und dem zu
zeigen was hier raus geworden ist ich
meine vor 4 stunden saß hier noch so aus
und jetzt ganz kurz warum mache ich das
überhaupt ich habe gemerkt dass es mir
immer wieder mehr spaß gemacht hat
irgendwelche leute zu überraschen
irgendwelchen leuten etwas gutes zu tun
zum beispiel das video mit ansgar wohin
mit ihm nach new york gefahren sind mit
dem das erste mal außerhalb von
deutschland waren und einfach zwei gute
tage im urlaub hatten haben wir
besonders viel spaß gemacht weil sie
eine überraschung waren und genau
deswegen in dieses video auch für alle
meine freunde eine überraschung aber
unsere ersten gäste sind da max na hallo
herr sogar dass politik etwas der extra
dafür vorbereitet haben schon auf dem
handy wir werden das kennen die typisch
die schicht und werden schauen was sie
zu unserem heimkino zu sagen tretet ein
guck dir mal das bild dann ist geist
krankt oder war's genau durch das nicht
passt das übel skyliners komplett für
uns alleine niemand da
[Musik]
hallo
[Applaus]
kurze frage ja ich habe ein ticket
bekommen über nachrichten musste ja man
muss es mir zeigen
ich hab dir gemietet bei wichtige -
ein traum
james cook management aus einem
schwimmbecken
herzlich willkommen in meinem privaten
kino ich freue mich dass sie alle da
seid und wir schauen heute vielen regeln
ich jemals von vielen dann kann ich das
ganze nicht gemacht viel spaß
[Musik]
danke fürs kommen meine lieben und weil
das hier kein normales kino ist die
andere mit aufräumen
das war ein voller erfolg wir hatten ein
gutes next und eine echte kino
experience gute stimmung und allgemein
hat es wirklich richtig laune gemacht
genau das war das ziel des videos und es
hat bestens funktioniert und danke euch
fürs zuschauen wenn ich das gefühl hat
dass man gerne like dann vergesse ich
denken als abonnieren um kein folgendes
video zu verpassen wir sehen uns am
sonntag wieder macht's gut
[Musik]